you guys wanted to tell the story of
working at a help desk and what it was
like it was an i.t help desk for school
mainly computer issues so
yeah they ended up being one of the most
defining
jobs i had mostly because it was so
miserable but looked good from the
outside
so i always had a strong interest in
computers got to know some people at
this
university doing contract work repairing
computers
and eventually a position opened up
for another spot that was a contract
position paid a little more
sounded a little better so i went for it
got it
eventually kind of moved around in the
ranks a little bit but there ended up
being a
full-time non-contract position open for
someone at the help desk and i was told
i should go for it
it sounded pretty nice it had benefits
it was better pay it was
more stable because it wasn't contract
so i went for it and i got the job
and i spent about two and a half years
there it was during this time
which i might get to a little later that
i decided i was going to
move towards being a programmer
so the day-to-day was
pretty miserable it was mostly just
answering phones answering tickets
answering emails and it was pretty much
always the same thing every day it was
mostly i forgot my password how do you
reset it
and it's like you you click the link and
you fill out the thing
and uh that was that was like the
majority of
the things to handle was just that over
and over and over
so after a while we kind of had a script
and we would just be like hey try this
do this this doesn't work do this and
eventually you know if they couldn't get
it at all they'd have to send an id
and prove that they are who they are and
then we could reset it
as you know the it behind the scenes
deal
however there were a lot of other things
that came in and a lot of other
interesting scenarios
we got calls for and stuff like that so
i started to kind of see
a more broad view of how everything
intertwined because
i was like i felt like i was the
connector i would like
connect whoever was having a problem to
the right team that could fix it
and you know after doing that for a
while you get really good at it
you're really good at figuring out who
does what in
a rather larger organization
so it was kind of defining for me i got
to kind of play around with
you know seeing where things might land
basically but also just going in and
doing that for eight to ten hours a day
was not exactly fun after a while there
were moments you know there were moments
with co-workers that were great there
were some calls that were great there's
some people you'd run into that were
great
but the majority of them were just kind
of monotone boring
things just kind of doing the same thing
repeating the same pattern
and getting interrupted by phone calls
all the time which is kind of a pet
peeve of mine i just don't like being
interrupted by phone calls to begin with
so
probably not the greatest fit for me
because of that but i
kind of learned to deal with it and i
think i grew his person became a better
person for it
if you get a chance to work at a help
desk
i think that you should do it but don't
plan on being there too long
i i feel like it's it is one of those
jobs that kind of
after a while kind of sucks the soul out
of you just the work is so repetitive
and
uh you run into a lot of people that
will like
numb your mind with the stuff they see
that's so uh
or the stuff they say that's so obvious
like how do i represent my password and
it's just like
you click the i forgot my password
button for the millionth time
like why why do you call me for this
so there's a lot of that and it's that's
just one example but there's like that
for a lot of things there's
stuff like how do i turn off my computer
it's like you
go to shut down turn it off you know
start button oh how do i do that you
click the
start button probably at the bottom left
and then you know like little basic walk
through stuff like that
which is kind of a bit crazy to have to
say to people after a while it feels
like
yeah but there are some good ones there
are there were a lot of legitimate
problems too and those are really
interesting i i actually enjoyed the
legitimate problems the ones that really
bugged me were the ones that were like
this isn't even a problem you just have
no idea what you're doing
uh i guess i guess it's a valid reason
to call the help desk but
i just felt like i could be more useful
than walking people through really
basic obvious stuff and that kind of
annoyed me after a while
which you know i guess sounds kind of uh
doesn't sound so great to say now feels
like you know i'm
i don't know something about that
doesn't sit right to say but it was kind
of the truth it was like an underlying
feeling and i i couldn't really help
that i was feeling that
you know because that's that's just the
way it is you feel what you feel
you can control how you express it but
you can't really
say you didn't feel it if you did so
i'm just taking a step back was
interesting it's definitely
definitely a good growing experience to
do something like that
it really tests your patience and also
teaches you a lot of patience because
you can't just like blow up on people
you know you have some days where you
get the same call over and over you get
really annoying calls or you start
getting frustrated or you can't get a
break because
no one else is there and the calls are
queued up all the way with like 10
people waiting and it's just like i'm
one guy
and i and you have to like log
everything in between calls so
while you're logging the previous one
the next one's calling and it's just
like holy crap can i get a moment to
myself to think
you know that sort of thing so you learn
to deal with that and to deal with that
a lot of times you just
you know you just kind of put people on
hold for a minute sometimes if you have
to because
things are piling up you can't scatter
yourself too wide you just got to be
like okay hold for a minute let me do
this
okay and continue so a lot of
managed time management became really
really important and just kind of
figuring out how to be polite with
people while you do that
so that's not a skill everybody has you
know especially more
technical people don't always have that
skill because they just spend so much
time
technical stuff i think and less on the
social aspect so
yeah yeah definitely uh definitely worth
doing
but not something you could do your
whole life in my opinion at least not
without
driving yourself crazy everyone else
that was doing that for longer than me
seemed like it was driving them crazy
they still continue to do it which
i didn't quite get but i did to some
extent like it's
it's in some places it's hard to find
something
better but usually you learn so much
that you can
find something better pretty quickly so
that's kind of what happened to me
it was also the time period was like
okay i need to go back to school i need
to
self-improve so i can do something else
i don't want to do this my whole life
so that's my quick and dirty version of
my helpdesk story
let me know if you have any questions
down below and
thanks for watching peace out